take a look at
that it's about my balls balls chafe
Mark
don't Rebecca transgender woman skid Los
Angeles December
iconic I found my meme ladies and
gentlemen Turn the Page there's
more wow these aren't as bad as I
thought I look like a witch I just look
like a witch who's like stuck in a boy
Whoa okay no I'm satisfied with us what
do you miss about your old life I don't
that I kill him I don't you
don't long for stability what um I don't
know if that really that was my that was
my favorite line from all of your videos
was it that was that Rebecca when you
had your head shaved was my favorite
personality I mean there's there's all
kinds of different personalities you
have but that that was particularly
fantastic thank you for my this is
definitely my Naomi Camp cell phone
moment I don't
know Johnny gang member it's not you Los
Angeles 2020 yeah I've never met any of
these people oh South Central Oh I
thought that was me for a second malvado
drug
dealer Ziggy porn actress Los Angeles
2019 yeah
painful yeah see this is how I sort of
would have seen myself I don't know
yeah I mean I don't know I think the
images tell more of a story I think the
quotes are a
little I'm so glad you're part of this
you're fun to
photograph certainly a
riot seven
photos thank you for the seven I think
that's more than anybody else in the
book yeah it's weird out of all your
even the Whitakers even subjects I mean
and whoo who are these women W these are
really interesting looking people damn I
am a very boring person in retrospect to
this I don't think so no I genuinely am
Mark gumml
hacker Caroline heroin addicted
prostitute Lynn crystal meth addict
Adrien alcoholic Amanda COC addict
sounds about right I think I found my
people yep that was
it I'm surprised are usually the sto
with like other people or cuz a lot of
these people seem to have more drawn out
I don't want to say intelligent but
well Berlin and Angel blue master and
slave I think that says everything
about I
know I think about the career